the nasty way
thing that most of us
to take for granted visiting friends and
family spending time outdoors and even
shopping trips to the supermarket as a
local counselor of 12 years standing
I've never experienced anything which
has such an enormous impact on everyday
life as the current covered 19 pandemic
as leader of Rochford District Council
I'm working very closely with Essex
County Council and the parish councils
and talking to other districts and
Borough Council's more often than I
would like these tears are not always
being in step and sometimes central
government feels very remote and far
removed from the needs of the local
residents however the current crisis
appears to have caused all the layers of
government closer together as we walk
towards supporting residents protecting
the NHS and saving lives
it isn't always plain sailing
but these extreme circumstances and
without president for some of us the
changes we have to implement but I'm
proud to be part of the public response
committed to keeping our communities
safe of course none of us can fail to be
impressed by those selfless heroes who
work in the health service who those who
are carers and those who are still
working in supermarkets for other
essential service providers such as the
war men I also salute those of you who
are helping with elderly and vulnerable
in our own neighborhoods providing them
with supplies drop in their dropping
them to their doorstep and making a
friendly phone call to keep up their
spirits you will be able to look back at
this time for that part with pride
knowing that you are stepping in to help
those in need in my role I have seen
firsthand those council officers who are
working with businesses volunteers and
faith leaders to provide much-needed
food supplies and simple simple benefit
friending to
of our vulnerable residents most
recently this has included the launch of
the rockford district community response
hub helpline for those who may have not
had other support networks to help them
at this time our refuge cooker is
continued to empty bins and working at
weekends to catch up with rounds missed
during the week because of style
shortages officers reporting business to
asset access government funding and
applying new financial release which
will hopefully migrate some of the in he
never told economic impact for them in
addition our teams were are working to
keep you updated and answer your social
media inquiries with our dedicated
customer service team working from home
to manage our live chat facility our
website and of course our phone calls I
also like to thank my fellow counselors
brought from all sides who are working
and tightly sadly we have had to urge
visitors not to come to our green spaces
for the time being and Havelock the car
parks are the locations but we are lucky
that our residents continue to have
spaces in in which they take their daily
exercise near their homes in these areas
that continue to rework these errors
will continue to be maintained and our
business team blabbers by our open
service team in other and in our in our
other car parks we have suspended
enforcement so that they no longer that
no user need to be fear of ticket for a
mistake I'm pleased that despite the
hardships we are facing it our local
businesses have been responsible working
with the Environmental Health Team and
the police and close where necessary
this means that although we have been
continuing
patrols so far we have not needed to use
the new enforcement powers available to
us we will continue to support our local
businesses going forward and also urge
all our residents to do the same where
possible within the guidelines that have
one government one of the big challenges
is to get back to normal
we never know whatever normal looks like
going forward and we will be a month
where we were where we're going to be a
month again this might sound like a pie
in the sky at the moment where the
country is in lockdown when the time
comes we will need to be ready in the
meantime the most important advice for
all residents present is that social
distancing is a central part of the
protecting each other and helping the
NHS and other services to cope please
follow government guidelines and stay
safe
you